this video we're going to look at Lucia
Talia's principle this particular
principle is heavily involved in our
work with dynamic equilibrium it enables
us to predict in which direction the
reversible reaction will move when we
change the conditions in the experiment
in essence it can be summarized with a
simple phrase that the equilibrium
position moves to minimize the effect of
a change in conditions
that's lechatelier's principle x' if
ever you require to quote it there are
three main ways that we can change the
conditions in experiment we can change
the temperature we can change the
pressure if we're dealing with gases or
with liquids we can change the
concentration so if we look at each of
these in turn in any reaction that we
have a plus B as an example going to a B
one direction of this reaction will be
exothermic and in this case let's say
it's the forward reaction and the other
reaction therefore will be an
endothermic reaction so we have heat
being produced in this direction and we
have heat being taken in in other words
a cooling effect in this direction so in
the case of this if we decide to
increase the temperature of the reaction
we were making this hotter
so the reactants will get hotter now to
minimize the effect of that what the
reactants will do will try to cool down
the reaction in other words to do the
opposite of making it hotter will
promote the reaction that cools it down
so if we increase the temperature in
this case we will promote the exothermic
reaction which means the dynamic
equilibrium will shift to the a plus B
side of this equation now for as of
chemists in this case that would not be
very useful because if we're doing this
reaction at all we probably want to
promote the actual product that we're
making so if we wanted to do this we
would reduce the temperature in other
words to cool it down and if we cool
down the reaction the reaction will try
to do the opposite of that
it will try to increase the temperature
which means it will promote the
exothermic reaction which is the forward
reaction so as a result if we cool down
the experiment the experiment will react
to try and increase the exothermic
reaction and therefore produce more of
our products a plus B if we start to
consider instead the number two
situation of pressure we have in the
case of and the best example to use here
is the harbor process we have a
situation where we have some nitrogen n2
plus some hydrogen h2 and it's going to
make in fact what's may remember it's a
reversible reaction and it's going to
make ammonia which is the 3 and H sorry
the 2 nh3 so
when we look at this if we look at the
reaction of these gases at this side of
the equation we have one molecule of
nitrogen but we have three molecules of
hydrogen making four molecules on this
side these four molecules exert a
pressure on the containers on the
opposite side of the reaction we just
have two ammonia molecules and those two
ammonia molecules are the ones exerting
the pressure on this side now if we
change the conditions of the pressure of
this reaction by increasing the pressure
we will try and put more pressure on the
container so if we wanted to decrease
the pressure the easiest way to do that
is to reduce the number of particles or
molecules that are pushing against the
side of the container so if we wanted to
decrease the number of molecules the
easiest way to do that is to move the
reaction towards the ammonia side
because when we move towards the ammonia
side there are less molecules present
we've gone from 4 to 2 for each of these
that react so by increasing the pressure
we encourage the reaction in the
direction that will decrease pressure
and that is the one to the side with the
least molecules so increase in the
pressure will promote the reaction that
reduces the number of molecules
so in the harbor prep at the Harbor
process reaction you'll know that the
conditions of the reaction are carried
out at 200 atmospheres
this is 200 times atmospheric pressure
so this is incredibly high pressure it
could be higher but the economics of
this means that if you try to increase
it higher you would not get your money's
worth from the reaction
so simply 200 atmosphere is what it's
limited to our third situation is of
concentration so again if we considered
the harbor process as a reaction of
concentration we have our nitrogen plus
our hydrogen forming our ammonia right
so as this reacts we maybe have only 5%
of our product is ammonia and 95% of our
chemicals as the reactants nitrogen and
hydrogen now if I can reduce the
concentration of ammonia by removing it
this will reduce the concentration of
ammonia on this side if we reduce the
concentration of ammonia on this side
then Lucia Talia's principles will say
that the reaction will compensate this
by moving more of the nitrogen ammonia
over to this side of the equation in
other words by removing this will reduce
that concentration so to increase the
concentration more ammonia or more
nitrogen hydrogen will move to this side
so will promote the forward reaction so
in the case of lechatelier's principle
by removing our product we increase the
forward reaction so remove the product
increases the forward reaction that is
in principle how the three different
changes of conditions
react with Leisha Talia's principle so
for one in summary Alicia Talia's
principles explains how the dynamic or
the equilibrium position in a dynamic
equilibrium can be changed by changing
the conditions and l'Italia Taylor's
chatelier's principle says that it will
change to minimize the effect of any
change that we make in the case of
temperature if we increase the
temperature of the reaction le
chatelier's principle says that we will
then promote the endothermic reaction if
we decrease the temperature will promote
the exothermic reaction in the case of
pressure if we increase the pressure we
will promote the reaction that serves to
reduce the number of molecules and the
case of the harbor process this is the
forward reaction if we reduce the
pressure we will rather promote the
reaction that reduces or increases the
number of molecules site and in the case
of concentration if we remove some of
the concentration of say the product
then the reaction of the forward
direction will be promoted to produce
more of that reaction if for instance we
added more ammonia into this we will
promote the reverse reaction that's a
summary of lechatelier's principle